Muchos piensan que la riqueza de Suiza
se debe únicamente a su condición de
paraíso fiscal,
pero lo cierto es que otros países como
Panamá, Chipre o incluso la república
africana de Liberia también ofrecen
condiciones fiscales muy favorables para
las empresas y sin embargo son países
pobres o de renta media baja.
Suiza es uno de los cinco países más
ricos del planeta y todo esto sin
comprometer los derechos humanos ni la
democracia,
al contrario el país helvético es una
de los lugares más igualitarios del
planeta cerca de otros sitios como
Noruega o Dinamarca, y su sistema democrático no
sólo permite y garantiza que los
ciudadanos voten cada cuatro años sino
que además les permite participar en
casi todas las decisiones políticas
cada cuatro meses.
Personalmente creo que Suiza tiene uno
de los mejores sistemas políticos del
mundo y ésa es la auténtica razón por
la cual son tan ricos.
Creo que de verdad todos los países
deberíamos tenerles como un modelo a
seguir hoy os voy a explicar por qué.
Lo primero que tenemos que saber es que
Suiza es una confederación, es decir,
está dividida en 26 regiones lo que
llaman cantones que son totalmente
independientes entre sí.
Lo único que tienen en común es el
ejército, la moneda, la política
exterior y la constitución. Para todo lo
demás son prácticamente estados
soberanos, para que os hagáis una idea
con un sueldo de 6.000 francos suizos
si viviéramos en el cantón de Jura
estaríamos pagando un IRPF, es
decir, un impuesto sobre nuestro sueldo
de un más o menos un 14% mientras que
si viviéramos en el cantón de Zuu, que
es uno de los cantones con los impuestos
más bajos,
pagaríamos solamente un 4%,
menos de la tercera parte.
Otro ejemplo es que en Ginebra
todos los comercios absolutamente todos
tienen que cerrar a partir de las seis
de la tarde mientras que en Zurich tienen
libertad de horarios.
Gracias a esta descentralización todos
los cantones pueden ajustar sus leyes a
las peculiaridades del territorio y de
la sociedad que tienen y lo que es más
importante pueden competir o sacar las
mejores legislaciones.
Esto explicaría también por qué en
Suiza en general tienen unos impuestos
tan bajos,
porque claro, si tú vives en un cantón
y de repente te suben mucho los
impuestos siempre te puedes mudar al
cantón de al lado que es mucho más
sencillo que emigrar a otro país
Todos los
países del mundo tienen un presidente o
un jefe de estado, ¿verdad?
Bueno pues Suiza es la excepción. ¡Ojo!
Esto no significa que los suizos vivan
en una especie de anarquía ellos votan
a un parlamento nacional que a su vez
elige a siete miembros de lo que podría
ser algo así como un consejo de
ministros que ellos llaman el consejo
federal.
De esas siete personas hay una que es la encargada
de representar al país en el exterior,
y ése es el presidente de Suiza, pero
realmente no tiene ningún poder
adicional sobre el resto de los miembros
del consejo federal.
De hecho, cada año van rotando. Fijaros
en el cambio de mentalidad, en cualquier
otro país
el presidente del gobierno o el primer
ministro es una figura muy importante,
sin embargo en Suiza es una figura
prácticamente simbólica porque casi
todas las decisiones se toman de forma
colegiada.
Pero sin duda alguna lo más conocido
del sistema político suizo es la
democracia directa casi todas las
decisiones importantes de la política
suiza se toman mediante referéndum.
Algunos son a nivel nacional y otros son
a nivel cantonal. Para conseguir que una
ley se someta a referéndum
basta con que cualquier ciudadano
consiga recoger 50 mil firmas y si esa
ley implica una modificación de la
constitución entonces tiene que recoger
100.000 firmas.
Es verdad que en otros países también se permite que
un ciudadano proponga una votación o un referéndum. En España, sin ir más lejos
bastan 500.000 firmas para proponer una
iniciativa legislativa popular,
sin embargo ésta no puede afectar la
Constitución mientras que en Suiza sí.
Así es como en este país se celebran
referéndums de forma habitual,
concretamente la gente se junta cuatro
veces al año para votar todos los
referéndums que se han ido proponiendo en
los últimos cuatro meses.
Por ejemplo este mes de junio se
reunieron para votar si querían una
renta básica universal o no. Pero en esa
misma elección también aprovecharon
para votar si querían un cambio en la
ley de reproducción asistida,
otra ley también otro reglamento para
regular el transporte público a nivel
federal y una enmienda a la ley de
acogida de refugiados. Y no os creáis que
estos referéndums tienen una
participación sorprendentemente alta,
concretamente en esta última votación
votaron más del 60% de la población.
Muchos pensaríais
que en una democracia tan directa es muy
normal que surja un líder populista que
quiera destruir el capitalismo, ¿verdad?
Pues resulta que Suiza es uno de los
iconos del libre mercado.
No olvidemos que es un país que está
aislado entre montañas y que apenas
tiene tierra cultivable con lo cual les
convienen firmar acuerdos de libre
comercio con prácticamente todos los
países. Pero mis queridos amigos
liberales y libertarios que sé que
muchos estáis viendo este vídeo
contened vuestra alegría por un momento.
Porque si bien es cierto que Suiza es un
país muy abierto al libre comercio no
lo es mucho más que la Unión Europea.
Es más, los suizos también subvencionan a su sector
primario y tienen una ley muy parecida a
la PAC europea y no sólo eso es que
también participan en los bloqueos y
sanciones comerciales a países como
Rusia o Irán.
Así que la única diferencia real en lo
que a libre comercio se refiere entre
Suiza y la Unión Europea es que los
suizos llevan comerciando libremente
desde 1874 mientras que el resto de
países europeos
llevamos abriéndonos al mercado
internacional solamente unas poquitas
décadas.
Bueno en realidad también hay otra
diferencia que ahora mismo vamos a ver
Efectivamente, Suiza es uno de los
pocos países neutrales del mundo. Esto
significa que nunca por principio
intervienen en ningún conflicto armado,
ni siquiera en la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
pese a que buena parte de la población
estaba en contra de Hitler.
Gracias a esto Suiza no ha tenido que
gastar dinero en recuperarse mientras
que el resto de países europeos se
gastaron una fortuna primero en matarse
unos a otros y luego en reconstruir
todos los destrozos de la guerra,
Suiza ha podido aprovechar todos esos
recursos para mejorar su estilo de vida
y es que en contra de lo que dice mucha
gente
el mayor enemigo de una economía es la
guerra.
Pero ojo todo esto no significa que
suiza no tenga ejército,
la diferencia es que sus fuerzas armadas
nunca irán a otro país a intervenir en
conflictos militares ajenos están
únicamente para defenderse de ataques
del exterior.
Y aquí es donde viene una de las pocas
cosas que no me gusta un pelo de este
país todos los ciudadanos helvéticos
están obligados a hacer el servicio
militar. Desde que llegan a la mayoría
de edad hasta que cumplen los 30 años
tienen que pasar un mes todos los años
en el ejército. Por supuesto que Suiza
no es el único país con servicio
militar obligatorio,
hay otros lugares que también lo tienen
como Noruega o Israel.
Sin embargo, a mí me parece que es una
violación de los derechos más
fundamentales porque nadie debería
poderte obligar a trabajar en algo en
lo que tú no quieres estar: ni en el
ejército, ni en la función pública, ni
en ninguna empresa. Tiene que ser una
decisión tuya. Pero en fin, algo malo
tendrían que tener en Suiza, ¿no?
Finalmente otro aspecto archiconocido de
la política suiza son sus impuestos.
Es verdad que hay muchas diferencias
entre un cantón y otro, pero en
general en todo el país
los impuestos son muy bajos y además
las leyes para montar nuevos negocios
son muy sencillitas y se pueden ver
muy fácil a través de internet, de
hecho, el gobierno suizo es también un
pionero en la transparencia y sí esto ha
permitido que muchas empresas
extranjeras se instalen en Suiza pero
también ha fomentado la creación de
un montón de empresas originarias de
este país. Y sí, vale, la banca suiza
tiene un peso muy importante en la
economía pero también hay muchos otros
sectores que no
nos paramos a pensar pero están ahí.
Hay un sector farmacéutico enorme con
empresas tan grandes como Novartis o
Hoffmann-La Roche, por no hablar de los relojes, el
turismo, las empresas de maquinaria de
precisión.
En general estoy seguro de que todos
si os paráis a pensar encontraréis alguna
empresa suiza que os suene, y todo esto
en un país con menos población que
México D.F. En fin, que como os decimos
siempre en VisualPolitik, lo que
hace rico a un país no son sus recursos
naturales ni su suerte, sino sus
instituciones y su sistema político. Y
en ese caso parece que a los suizos no
les ha ido nada mal.
En cualquier caso, ésta es mi opinión. ¿Vosotros qué
pensáis? ¿Creéis que vuestro país
podría mejorar si imitara un poquitín al
sistema suizo?
Podéis escribirme vuestras ideas en los
comentarios de este vídeo. Si alguien
quiere profundizar más en este tema os he dejado varios links en la
descripción. Si os ha gustado el vídeo, dadle a like y suscribiros si no lo habéis
hecho todavía. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.